Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. You knew it must come to this, sooner or later, Toad, the badger explained severely. You've disregarded all the warnings we've given you, you've gone on squandering the money your father left you, and you're giving us animals a bad name in the district by your furious driving and your smashes and your rows with the police. Independence is all very well, but we animals never allow our friends to make fools of themselves beyond a certain limit,
感谢您收听《历史的真相》（The Rest Is History）。如需获取每周额外剧集、无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。“你早该想到会有这一天，蟾蜍，”獾严厉地解释道，“你无视了我们给你的所有警告，挥霍着你父亲留给你的钱财，而且你那疯狂的驾驶、撞车以及与警察的争吵，让我们这些动物在这一带名声扫地。独立固然很好，但我们动物从不允许朋友在一定限度之外做出愚蠢的行为，”
and that limit you've reached. Now, you're a good fellow in many respects, and I don't want to be too hard on you. I'll make one more effort to bring you to reason. You will come with me into the smoking-room, and there you will hear some facts about yourself, and we'll see whether you come out of that room the same Toad that you went in.' He took Toad firmly by the arm, let him into the smoking-room, and closed the door behind them. "'That's no good said the rat contemptuously talking to toad will never cure him he'll say anything so dominic that was that was your choice of reading and i have to say uh it's it's a superlatively good one um from
“而你已经触及了那个限度。说实话，你在许多方面还是个好伙伴，我不想对你太苛刻。我会再努力一次，让你清醒过来。你跟我进吸烟室，在那里你会听到一些关于你自己的事实，我们看看你走出那个房间时，还是不是进去时的那个蟾蜍。”他坚定地抓住蟾蜍的手臂，把他带进吸烟室，并在他们身后关上了门。“那没用，”老鼠轻蔑地说，“跟蟾蜍说话永远治不好他，他什么话都说得出来。”所以，多米尼克，那是你选择的读物，我不得不说，嗯，它非常出色，嗯，来自
kenneth graham's wind in the willows um and toad of toad hall a character with whom boris johnson has often been compared he um he's always getting into smashes isn't he he he lies he drives cars fast he escapes from prison dressed as washing woman um non-stop scrapes um and um and boris has been well, I mean, he's – the grease piglets he's been called, but he's finally been caught and turned into bacon. He has indeed. So, Tom, you read that with great relish, and I have to say you make a very good badger. Thank you.
肯尼思·格雷厄姆的《柳林风声》，嗯，还有《蟾蜍庄园的蟾蜍》，这是一个经常被拿来与鲍里斯·约翰逊相提并论的角色。他，嗯，他总是惹祸上身，不是吗？他撒谎，他开快车，他打扮成洗衣妇从监狱逃跑，嗯，没完没了的麻烦，嗯，还有，鲍里斯一直被，我的意思是，他被——人们叫他“油腻小猪”，但他最终还是被抓住了，变成了培根。确实如此。所以，汤姆，你读得津津有味，我不得不说你演的獾非常棒。谢谢。
Thank you. I wouldn't have had you down as a natural. I think you're more of a rat than a badger, but I think you did a very good badger there. Thank you. Yes, I think this is an extraordinary day. We are recording at 11 o'clock on Thursday, the 7th of July after what has probably been the most extraordinary two days in modern British Prime Ministerial history,
谢谢。我本来没觉得你有这方面的天赋。我觉得你更像老鼠而不是獾，但我认为你刚才那段獾的表演非常出色。谢谢。是的，我认为这是非同寻常的一天。我们是在7月7日星期四上午11点进行录音的，此前经历了现代英国首相史上可能最非同寻常的两天，
possibly British Prime Ministerial history. Full stop. Since Walpole. history possibly british prime ministerial history full stop since walpole um so for instance i mean the obvious parallel is with the defenestration of mrs thatcher do you think it's a more it's been a more remarkable 24 hours than that um the tone is so utterly different tom it is isn't it regular listeners will know that we did a podcast about how prime ministers fall and we talked about the defenestration of mrs thatcher which for those people of our age kind of centrist daddish people is this kind of um it was felt like an absolute watershed didn't it but the tone of mrs thatcher's phone and we'll come back to mrs thatcher's fall in the autumn because we're planning an episode about that.
可能是英国首相史上。句号。自沃波尔以来。历史，可能是英国首相史上，句号，自沃波尔以来。嗯，所以，举个例子，我的意思是，显而易见的类比是撒切尔夫人的下台。你认为这比那24小时更引人注目吗？嗯，基调完全不同，汤姆。确实是这样，不是吗？经常收听节目的听众会知道，我们做过一期关于首相如何下台的播客，我们谈到了撒切尔夫人的下台，对于我们这个年纪的人，那种中间派、老派的人来说，这是一种，嗯，感觉就像一个绝对的分水岭，不是吗？但撒切尔夫人下台时的基调，我们会在秋天回到撒切尔夫人的下台这个话题，因为我们计划做一期关于那个的节目。
That was a... It was high drama. It was high melodrama. But everybody in it was possessed of a sort of dignity, weren't they? I mean, Mrs. Thatcher, even when she wept as the car carried her away. It was a Shakespearean tragedy, whereas this is kind of opera buffet. It's pantomime. It's carry on, carry on Downing Street.
那是一场……那是一场高潮迭起的戏剧。那是高度的通俗剧。但其中的每个人都拥有一种尊严，不是吗？我的意思是，撒切尔夫人，即使当她在车子载她离开时流泪的时候。那是一场莎士比亚式的悲剧，而这更像是滑稽歌剧。这是哑剧。这是《随心所欲》（Carry On）系列，这是《随心所欲》唐宁街。
For me, well, it's that sort of coupled with this sort of Game of Thrones role playing, isn't it? So that moment last night, late last night, when there were two rival delegations in Downing Street of ministers, there were the sort of the people led by the Chancellor of a day, Nadeem Zahawi, telling Boris Johnson he had to go. Then there were the loyalists, Nadeem Torres and co, telling him he had to stay.
对我来说，嗯，这与那种《权力的游戏》式的角色扮演结合在一起，不是吗？所以昨晚那个时刻，昨晚很晚的时候，当唐宁街有两拨对立的部长代表团时，有一群由当时的财政大臣纳迪姆·扎哈维领导的人，告诉鲍里斯·约翰逊他必须离开。然后是保皇派，纳丁·多里斯等人，告诉他他必须留下。
He refused to leave and then sort of wildly flailing and lashing out, sacked Michael Gove and called him a snake. Brief to the press that Gove was a snake. I thought at that point, I mean, at that point, that was the point at which it tipped into just outright ridiculousness. Well, yes. So, I mean, obviously a kind of a comical element. So Michael Gove is, I think, even his enemies would acknowledge is probably the most effective minister in the current government um celebrated as a minister who actually gets things done and he is in charge of uh the government's leveling up department which according to the
他拒绝离开，然后疯狂地挥舞拳头，解雇了迈克尔·戈夫，并称他为蛇。向媒体简报说戈夫是一条蛇。我想在那一刻，我的意思是，在那一刻，那是事情演变成彻头彻尾的荒谬的时刻。嗯，是的。所以，我的意思是，显然有一种滑稽的成分。所以迈克尔·戈夫，我认为，即使是他的敌人也会承认，他可能是现任政府中最有效的部长，嗯，作为一位真正能把事情做成的部长而闻名，他负责，嗯，政府的“升级”部门，根据
prime minister himself is at the heart of his entire mission and and i think that by the end of yesterday evening they had one minister left in that department so to sack gove on one level obviously deeply satisfying for johnson because of course there's history there and we should explain for for non-british listeners that johnson and gove were were kind of allies in the brexit campaign gove was backing backing Johnson throughout that campaign, then was going to back him as a candidate to be prime minister. And it all went disastrously wrong because Gove basically realised that Johnson would make a terrible prime minister and said so. And everything he said was basically accurate and stabbed him in the backs and and then johnson has has been obliged to bring
首相本人所说，这是他整个使命的核心，而且，我认为到昨天晚上结束时，他们那个部门只剩下一位部长了。所以解雇戈夫，在某种程度上显然让约翰逊感到非常满足，因为当然，他们之间有历史，我们应该为非英国听众解释一下，约翰逊和戈夫在脱欧运动中曾是盟友，戈夫在整个运动中一直支持约翰逊，然后本来打算支持他作为首相候选人。但这一切都极其糟糕地搞砸了，因为戈夫基本上意识到约翰逊会成为一个糟糕的首相，并说了出来。他所说的一切基本上都是准确的，并从背后捅了他一刀，然后约翰逊不得不把
gov back in because basically gave us the best minister there is um so on that level on one level deeply satisfying for johnson to to to get rid of gov like that but on the other massively massively irresponsible because now he johnson is going to step down that department still has no minister so that moment tom when uh johnson sacked michael gove i thought although that was that was couched in this sort of i fight on i fight to to win terminology derived from mrs thatcher in 1990 i thought that was the moment where it was very clear he wasn't yeah realistically going to continue as prime minister because having sacked Michael Gove, having lost all these other people, it was inconceivable that he could continue. But obviously he went this morning.
戈夫请回来，因为基本上戈夫是最好的部长，嗯，所以在那一层面上，约翰逊能那样摆脱戈夫感到非常满足，但在另一方面，这极其极其不负责任，因为现在他，约翰逊，要下台了，那个部门仍然没有部长。所以那一刻，汤姆，当，嗯，约翰逊解雇迈克尔·戈夫时，我想，尽管那是用那种“我战斗，我战斗是为了赢”的术语包装的，源自1990年的撒切尔夫人，但我认为那是很明显他不会，是的，现实地讲，继续担任首相的时刻，因为解雇了迈克尔·戈夫，失去了所有这些人，他不可能继续下去了。但显然他今天早上走了。
And, you know, as we said, the prime ministers have gone in different circumstances before they've been toppled by you know the public in general elections they've been toppled by internal party revolts but i can't think of a process that's ever been simultaneously uh sort of so protracted but in such a ludicrous and lurid manner i mean theresa may's departure was very protracted but it was sort of there was something excruciating about it and and she's a somebody of an immense seriousness yeah so there was something quite sort of even for people who despise Theresa May there was something quite tragic about it nobody could say that I think about Boris Johnson I mean it's just something absolutely ludicrous yeah I mean the the um there was no dignity whatsoever and I think it will it will be looked back at as as a kind of moment of of high grotesque comedy but to
而且，你知道，正如我们所说，首相们以前在不同的情况下离开过，他们被公众在大选中推翻，他们被党内叛乱推翻，但我无法想象一个过程，曾经同时，嗯，如此漫长，却又以如此荒谬和耸人听闻的方式进行。我的意思是，特蕾莎·梅的离开非常漫长，但它有一种，有一种令人痛苦的东西，而且，她是一个非常有严肃性的人，是的，所以即使对于那些鄙视特蕾莎·梅的人来说，也有一些相当悲剧性的东西。我认为没人能那样评价鲍里斯·约翰逊，我的意思是，这只是绝对荒谬，是的，我的意思是，嗯，根本没有任何尊严，我认为人们回顾它时，会把它看作是一种高度怪诞的喜剧时刻，但要
reiterate you know britain is a country facing multiple crises um and essentially to have lost pretty much the whole government you know and and willingly to have allowed that to happen simply in the cause of defending his own prime ministership it's actually the most monstrous display of irresponsibility that i can think of from a leading british politician agreed i agree monstrously irresponsible because you think about you know because what's what what has happened however much entertainment it may have provided uh politics aficionados over the past day or so there are people who are facing i mean essentially a kind of a collapse into poverty inflation going through the roof massive massive spikes in in energy prices coming up huge huge problems and what has happened over the past years has made the ability
重申，你知道，英国是一个面临多重危机的国家，嗯，本质上，几乎失去了整个政府，你知道，而且心甘情愿地允许这种情况发生，仅仅是为了捍卫他自己的首相职位，这实际上是我能想到的来自英国主要政治家最骇人听闻的不负责任的表现。同意，我同意，骇人听闻的不负责任，因为你想想，你知道，因为发生了什么，无论它在过去一天左右为政治爱好者提供了多少娱乐，都有人面临，我的意思是，本质上是一种陷入贫困的崩溃，通货膨胀飙升，能源价格即将出现巨大的巨大涨幅，巨大的巨大问题，而过去几年发生的事情使得
of the government to respond to that much much lower than it would otherwise have been yeah well that's why the question is now does he stay on to the autumn as he wants or do they actually move much more quickly do they defenestrate him do they get an interim prime minister who can work with a a team of sort of seasoned people to try and deal with some of this cost of living stuff before a new leader comes in? I guess late summer or autumn, maybe the party conference. But can Boris Johnson conceivably preside over some sort of temporary cabinet full of people who've stabbed him, not just in the back? Well, you know, or is there some kind of will there be some because the whole thing about the british constitution is that it's unwritten and i'm sure we'll come to
政府应对这些问题的能力比原本要低得多。是的，嗯，这就是为什么现在的问题是，他是否会像他想要的那样留任到秋天，还是他们实际上会更快地采取行动？他们会让他下台吗？他们会找一位临时首相，能够与一个由经验丰富的人组成的团队合作，试图在新的领导人上任之前处理一些生活成本问题吗？我猜是夏末或秋天，也许是党代会。但鲍里斯·约翰逊能想象自己主持某种临时的内阁吗？内阁里全是捅过他的人，不仅仅是在背后？嗯，你知道，或者是否会有某种，因为英国宪法的全部意义在于它是不成文的，我相信我们会谈到
that because that essentially lies at the heart of everything that's been happening recently but maybe a new protocol will be written into the british constitution that um in a situation like this you revert to the norm norm that existed 24 hours before, and maybe all the ministers will come back in and resume their position. And of course, to reiterate, we're recording this 11 o'clock on Thursday morning. So by the time you listen to this,
这一点，因为这本质上是最近发生的一切的核心，但也许英国宪法中会写入一个新的协议，嗯，在这种情况下，你恢复到24小时前存在的常态，也许所有的部长都会回来并恢复他们的职位。当然，要重申，我们是在周四上午11点录音的。所以当你听到这个的时候，
perhaps this will all have been resolved. So Tom, since we are obviously a history podcast and our political punditry, though in our own minds, absolutely first class is probably not even fifth class in the eyes of some of our listeners. So let's talk about some of the history here. So Boris Johnson has always seen himself, hasn't he,
也许这一切都已经解决了。所以汤姆，既然我们显然是一个历史播客，而我们的政治评论，虽然在我们自己看来是绝对一流的，但在我们的一些听众眼中可能连五流都算不上。所以让我们谈谈这里的一些历史。所以鲍里斯·约翰逊一直把自己看作是，不是吗，
as a historical character, isn't that right? And particularly a character from classical history. Yes, so he studied classics at university. And for most people who study the ancient world, it is a distant period. It does not do what the study of classical languages and ancient history did for generations and generations of European leaders, which was to provide a kind of how to do politics course. I mean, that's what it was for Machiavelli. That's what it was for people in the Cromwellian period, for Millords throughout the 18th century, for French revolutionaries. Classics provided guides on how to behave, on how to behave politically, on how to behave morally. That has not been the case for many, many years. And the salience of classics in the education of people in Britain obviously has declined massively. So Johnson in that sense is a throwback. He is someone who, for whom classics
一个历史人物，不是吗？特别是古典历史中的人物。是的，所以他在大学学习古典学。对于大多数学习古代世界的人来说，这是一个遥远的时期。它并没有像古典语言和古代历史的研究对一代又一代的欧洲领导人所做的那样，提供一种“如何从政”的课程。我的意思是，这就是马基雅维利的目的。这就是克伦威尔时期的人、18世纪的贵族、法国革命者的目的。古典学提供了关于如何表现、如何从政治上表现、如何从道德上表现的指南。这种情况已经很多年没有发生了。而且古典学在英国人的教育中的显著性显然已经大幅下降。所以约翰逊在那个意义上是一个倒退。他是一个，对他来说，古典学
is pretty much central to his education. But I think also the thing that is intriguing about him is that I think he studied it as an example of how to get ahead. I think he had a properly Greek Roman understanding of how Fortuna, Tyche, Chance, this great goddess has her favorites and i think he's he genuinely you know in a kind of inchoate sense but a sense that does seem to me to have been authentic saw himself as fortune's favorite and for so long he was but of course it it's the nature it's the essence of tragedy it's the essence of um the cruelty and the humor of fortuna that she raises her for her favorites up only to hurl them down and the humour of Fortuna that she raises her favourites up only to hurl them down. And the joke that Fortune has played on Johnson is a peculiarly cruel one, I think. Well, let's talk a bit about classical parallels because some people,
几乎是他教育的核心。但我认为关于他，最耐人寻味的事情是，我认为他学习它作为如何出人头地的例子。我认为他有一种真正的希腊罗马式的理解，关于“命运”（Fortuna）、“时机”（Tyche）、“机会”，这位伟大的女神有她的宠儿，而且我认为他真诚地，你知道，以一种模糊的感觉，但对我来说似乎是真实的感觉，把自己看作是命运的宠儿。而且很长一段时间里他确实是，但当然，这是悲剧的本质，这是，嗯，命运的残酷和幽默的本质，她提升了她的宠儿，只是为了把他们摔下来。而命运对约翰逊开的玩笑，我认为是一个特别残酷的玩笑。好吧，让我们谈谈古典类比，因为有些人，
so our producer, Joey, asked at the beginning whether it was like the Ides of March, whether that was a reasonable parallel. Is that how Boris Johnson himself, I mean, clearly he would love that parallel, wouldn't he? He'd like to see himself as Caesar brought down by sort of weedy politicians and senators who envy the great man. Do you think that's how he sees it, Tom? I think, well, to a degree.
所以我们的制片人乔伊在开始时问这是否像“三月十五日”（凯撒遇刺日），这是否是一个合理的类比。鲍里斯·约翰逊本人是这样看的吗？我的意思是，显然他会喜欢那个类比，不是吗？他会喜欢把自己看作是被嫉妒伟人的卑微政客和参议员推翻的凯撒。你认为他是这样看的吗，汤姆？我想，嗯，在某种程度上。
So Caesar did cast himself as the kind of the tribune of the people. And he did become impatient with the conventions of the Republican frame of government and did want to establish a kind of personal relationship between him and the mass of the people who he felt were backing him, in fact, were backing him. As we've said many times caesar was a great populist absolutely and and that has been um a feature of johnson i mean he hasn't cast himself as a kind of a dictator as caesar did but he's cast himself as a presidential figure so even even as he was you know his government was resigning all around him he was saying that
所以凯撒确实把自己塑造成了人民的保民官。他确实对共和政府框架的惯例变得不耐烦，确实想在他和支持他的人民大众之间建立一种个人关系，他觉得他们支持他，事实上，确实支持他。正如我们多次说过的，凯撒是一位伟大的民粹主义者，绝对是，而且那一直是约翰逊的一个特征，我的意思是，他没有把自己塑造成像凯撒那样的独裁者，但他把自己塑造成了一个总统式的人物。所以即使，即使当他的政府在他周围辞职时，他也在说
his mandate derived from the votes of of the people who had actually voted for the conservative party i mean it's a parliamentary system not a presidential system exactly the mandate was for individual mps not for him exactly exactly but he was saying i can't be you can't bring me down because i have the backing of the people so to that extent uh the the echoes are there i guess of caesar but the the hero um johnson's hero has always been pericles and i saw actually that he he he was being interviewed by ch by Chris Mason on a couple of days ago about the whole imbroglio, just as Javid and Sunak, the health and chancellor of the health secretary and chancellor of the Exchequer were about to resign. And in behind him, he had a bust of Pericles, who was the great democratic leader of Athens. So tell us a bit about Pericles. And we'll do a whole podcast about Pericles. But tell us, give the great democratic leader of Athens. Yeah so tell us a bit about
他的授权来自实际投票给保守党的人民的选票，我的意思是，这是一个议会制，而不是总统制。完全正确，授权是给个别议员的，而不是给他的。完全正确，完全正确，但他一直在说，你们不能推翻我，因为我有人民的支持。所以在这个程度上，嗯，回声是存在的，我猜是凯撒的，但英雄，嗯，约翰逊的英雄一直是伯里克利。而且我实际上看到，他，他几天前接受了克里斯·梅森关于整个混乱局面的采访，就在贾维德和苏纳克，卫生大臣和财政大臣即将辞职的时候。在他身后，他有一个伯里克利的半身像，他是雅典伟大的民主领袖。所以给我们讲讲伯里克利。我们会做一整期关于伯里克利的播客。但告诉我们，给雅典伟大的民主领袖。是的，所以给我们讲讲
Pericles and we'll do a whole podcast about Pericles but tell us give us a small sense of him. So Pericles was um he was of aristocratic pedigree a very good of a kind of slightly notorious but but very very influential family and he so rigged the democratic system, he made himself so much the favourite of the people that, in effect, he ruled as a kind of first minister in the democracy. And that's always been Johnson's role model. But I think that he's flattering himself with that. I don't think that Johnson has any real point of comparison with Pericles at all. Because Pericles was more serious or more substantial? He was more substantial, yeah.
伯里克利，我们会做一整期关于伯里克利的播客，但告诉我们，给我们一点关于他的感觉。所以伯里克利是，嗯，他出身贵族，一个非常好的，一种稍微有点臭名昭著但非常非常有影响力的家庭，他操纵了民主制度，他让自己成为了人民的宠儿，以至于实际上，他作为民主制度中的第一大臣进行统治。那一直是约翰逊的榜样。但我认为他在用那个来恭维自己。我不认为约翰逊与伯里克利有任何真正的可比性。因为伯里克利更严肃或更充实？他更充实，是的。
He was more substantial. If we'd been recording this while Johnson was still clinging on in Downing Street, I would have said that the parallels actually were with those who made themselves tyrants in Greek city-states. I mean, the refusal to accept the the kind of civic norms is what was characterized is what characterized this crisis and that was
他更充实。如果我们是在约翰逊还赖在唐宁街的时候录制这个，我会说类比实际上是那些在希腊城邦中让自己成为暴君的人。我的意思是，拒绝接受，嗯，那种公民规范是这次危机的特征，而那一直是
always the kind of the pressure point in both the cities of greece and in rome under its republican system was where its its great men its leaders refused to accept what the romans called the mos maiorum the customs of the ancestors the unwritten rules the unwritten conventions of behavior and morality that should it was felt properly govern how people behaved and it's though it's it's ironically it's the kind of the mos maiorum the the the customs of the ancestors that johnson has repeatedly kind of trodden down and and actually one of the things that romans in particular provide that the model that romans provided was knowing how to make a good exit so actually there's a kind of parallel with otho
希腊城邦和罗马共和制度下一直以来的压力点，就是它的伟人、它的领导人拒绝接受罗马人所说的“祖宗成法”（mos maiorum），即祖先的习俗、不成文的规则、不成文的行为和道德准则，人们认为这些应该适当地管理人们的行为。而且，讽刺的是，这正是约翰逊反复践踏的“祖宗成法”，而且实际上，罗马人提供的模型之一就是知道如何体面地退出。所以实际上，这与奥托有一种类比，
who was one of the emperors in the year of the four emperors 8069 who who'd been a notorious ruy he'd been a friend of nero's he'd um he'd kind of gone out it a bit kind of like darius guppy and and and boris that they they as young men they kind of go out into the seamier reaches of rome and they would attack people and they're particular my god that is like so they're particularly what nero and off they would do they they they they they kind of take distinguished looking passers-by and and toss them in cloaks which is a very kind of public school thing to do isn't it um and and and and off though was the husband of papaya sabina who very much friend of the show we've talked about her quite a lot much or you claim that nero was
他是公元69年“四帝之年”的皇帝之一，他曾经是一个臭名昭著的浪荡子，他曾经是尼禄的朋友，他，嗯，他有点像达里乌斯·格皮和鲍里斯，他们，作为年轻人，他们进入了罗马更阴暗的角落，他们会攻击人，而且他们特别，天哪，这就像，所以他们特别，尼禄和奥托会做的事情，他们，他们，他们会抓住看起来很显眼的行人，把他们扔进斗篷里，这是一种非常公立学校的做法，不是吗？嗯，而且，而且，奥托是波培娅·萨比娜的丈夫，她是节目的好朋友，我们谈论过她很多次，或者你声称尼禄是
absolutely yeah so attached to her that he beat her to death yes but he he first of all he had to get rid of off though uh which he did by sending her off to him off to govern portugal right um and uh but then when nero died city erupted into civil war um off they backed galba who was the kind of the big military man in spain um came to rome thought that he was going to be groomed as um galba's successor uh wasn't so basically sponsored a coup against galba rather like boris sponsored a coup against theresa may galba was a rather theresa may figure kind of very serious solemn ponderous figure um so off they became emperor the legions on the rhine didn't like this they supported that the a very fat guy called vitalius he stopped on his march to eat pasties from that kind of thing yes
绝对是的，如此依恋她，以至于他把她打死了。是的，但他首先必须摆脱奥托，他通过把她送到他那里，送到葡萄牙去统治，做到了这一点，对吧？而且，嗯，但后来当尼禄去世时，城市爆发了内战，奥托支持了加尔巴，他是西班牙的一位大军事人物，来到罗马，以为他会被培养成加尔巴的继任者，结果没有，所以基本上赞助了一场针对加尔巴的政变，就像鲍里斯赞助了一场针对特蕾莎·梅的政变。加尔巴是一个相当特蕾莎·梅式的人物，一种非常严肃、庄重、沉重的人物，所以奥托成为了皇帝。莱茵河上的军团不喜欢这样，他们支持那个，一个非常胖的家伙叫维特里乌斯，他在行军途中停下来吃馅饼，那种事情，是的，
stalls didn't he exactly um and vitalius's army not actually led by vitalius because he was still busy go eating um met with otho's army in northern italy and otho's army was defeated and the news was brought to otho and he could have carried on fighting that he had enough troops to carry on fighting and the praetorians who backed him wanted him to carry on fighting so nadine doris jacob reese mogg that kind of those kind of people they were saying to otho yeah go on carry on fighting and otho said no i'm not going to do that because this would be bad for rome it would be bad for my city it'd be bad for the roman people um did he really say that tom this is what he i think he did and and i think we can rely on the gist of it because satonius's
摊位，不是吗？完全正确，而且维特里乌斯的军队实际上不是由维特里乌斯领导的，因为他还在忙着吃，在意大利北部遇到了奥托的军队，奥托的军队被击败了，消息传到了奥托那里，他本可以继续战斗，他有足够的军队继续战斗，支持他的近卫军希望他继续战斗，所以纳丁·多里斯、雅各布·里斯-莫格那种人，他们对奥托说，是的，继续，继续战斗。而奥托说，不，我不会那样做，因为这对罗马不利，这对我的城市不利，这对罗马人民不利。他真的那样说了吗，汤姆？这是他，我想他确实说了，而且我认为我们可以相信它的大意，因为苏托尼乌斯的
father was at his side when he gave this speech and obviously reported it sat atonius who's the the biographer from whom we get this and also said i am unwilling to prioritize my personal interests my my selfish interests over those of my fellow citizens and so he killed himself fell on his sword and i think that that's the kind of model of civic rectitude that the british should follow that boris johnson could have could have picked up on but i'm afraid signally perhaps he didn't study that that section that period no well is there no roman example i mean is there a good roman example of somebody clinging on when they you know clinging on, doing the anti-Otho. So Nero, I mean, he tried to run away, didn't he?
父亲在他发表这篇演讲时就在他身边，显然报道了它。苏托尼乌斯，我们从中得到传记的传记作家，也说，我不愿将我的个人利益，我的自私利益置于我的同胞之上，所以他自杀了，倒在了自己的剑上。我认为这就是英国人应该遵循的公民正直的典范，鲍里斯·约翰逊本可以借鉴的，但我恐怕，显著地，也许他没有研究那一部分，那个时期。不，好吧，没有罗马的例子吗？我的意思是，有没有一个好的罗马例子，有人在他们，你知道，赖着不走，做反奥托的事情。所以尼禄，我的意思是，他试图逃跑，不是吗？
He kills himself. He falls on his sword. I mean, there's a feeling that, you know, it's an undignified thing to do. Yeah. And there were various people later on in the history of Rome, aren't there, who are sort of, they're killed by Praetorians and their head is used as a football or they're thrown into the Tiber or yeah all these kinds of things but that's more sudden isn't it yeah there's not an example yeah there's not really an example of somebody who you know who has the opportunity to make a dignified exit but just risibly refuses to do so i suppose i mean even james the second
他自杀了。他倒在了自己的剑上。我的意思是，有一种感觉，你知道，这是一件不体面的事情。是的。而且后来在罗马历史上还有各种各样的人，不是吗？他们被近卫军杀死，他们的头被当作足球，或者他们被扔进台伯河，或者，是的，所有这些事情，但这更突然，不是吗？是的，没有一个例子，是的，真的没有一个例子，有人，你知道，有机会做出体面的退出，但只是可笑地拒绝这样做。我想，我的意思是，即使是詹姆斯二世
has the decency to flee England in 1688. So this is why I think that it is Fortuna's great joke that she has raised him to the pinnacle. Yeah. Only to make him a figure of mockery because he has spurned the chance to behave with dignity. Which of course Theresa May did and Mrs. Thatcher did. Well, in the summer of 2019 Max Hastings who had edited Johnson at the Telegraph and and has subsequently um established a kind of cottage industry of writing a rump thing about your incredible increasingly
也有体面在1688年逃离英国。所以这就是为什么我认为这是命运的伟大玩笑，她把他提升到了顶峰。是的。只是为了让他成为嘲笑的对象，因为他拒绝了表现得体面的机会。当然，特蕾莎·梅做到了，撒切尔夫人也做到了。好吧，在2019年夏天，马克斯·黑斯廷斯，他曾在《每日电讯报》编辑过约翰逊，并且随后，嗯，建立了一种关于写关于你令人难以置信的、日益增长的
furious opinion piece is saying that he is absolutely you know he should he should be thrown into the sea despite having having employed him, right? Despite having employed him. Well, he says, he predicted in the summer, he said, Johnson's premiership will almost certainly reveal a contempt for rules, precedent, order, and stability. He will surely come to regret securing the prize for which he has struggled so long,
愤怒的评论文章的家庭手工业，说他绝对是，你知道，他应该被扔进海里，尽管雇佣过他，对吧？尽管雇佣过他。好吧，他说，他在夏天预测，他说，约翰逊的首相任期几乎肯定会揭示对规则、先例、秩序和稳定的蔑视。他肯定会后悔争取到他奋斗了这么久的奖品，
because the experience of the premiership will lay bare his absolute unfitness for it. So that's a bit, isn't that very similar to the line about Galba? Yes. Everybody would have thought he would have been a great emperor if he only, but that is the fortune of, I mean, that is the tragedy, isn't it? As it were, that's the essence of tragedy. In securing the prize you seek, you expose your own inadequacy.
因为首相的经历将暴露他绝对不适合它。所以这有点，这不和关于加尔巴的那句话很相似吗？是的。每个人都会认为他会成为一位伟大的皇帝，如果他只是，但这就是命运，我的意思是，这就是悲剧，不是吗？正如人们所说，这就是悲剧的本质。在获得你寻求的奖品时，你暴露了自己的不足。
So one last thing about the dignity point tom is that um i think we forget partly because we've been inured to it because of the example of mr trump um how unusual it is to have an undignified exit in british politics so if you look back i mean theresa may i think everybody recognized that she was sort of trying her best, but when the game was up, she gave that sort of awful, excruciating, tearful statement outside number 10. Cameron left within hours of the Brexit referendum. He was humming, wasn't he? Well, he hummed.
所以关于尊严的一点，汤姆，是，嗯，我认为我们忘记了，部分是因为我们已经因为特朗普先生的例子而习以为常了，在英国政治中有一个不体面的退出是多么不寻常。所以如果你回顾过去，我的意思是，特蕾莎·梅，我认为每个人都认识到她是在，嗯，尽她最大的努力，但当游戏结束时，她在唐宁街10号外发表了那种可怕的、令人痛苦的、泪流满面的声明。卡梅伦在脱欧公投后几小时内就离开了。他在哼歌，不是吗？好吧，他哼了。
That's after the misunders. Two things have now been conflated. So he actually hummed a few weeks later when it was obvious that May would succeed him without really a contest. And he said, OK, I'll have to go more quickly than I thought. And then he didn't hum on. Everyone thinks he hummed on the morning, but he didn't. But he left immediately at a point, actually, when no one was calling for him to leave.
那是误解之后。两件事现在被混为一谈了。所以他实际上在几周后哼了歌，当时很明显梅会在没有真正竞争的情况下接替他。他说，好吧，我得比我想象的走得更快。然后他没有继续哼。每个人都认为他在那天早上哼了，但他没有。但他立即离开了一个点，实际上，当时没有人要求他离开。
Well, actually, I mean, this was something that was very much picked up on yesterday morning. But Gordon Brown. Yeah. After the indecisive election in was it 2010 hung around in Downing Street. Trying to form a coalition. Trying to form a coalition. And there was a slight sense that this was not a kind of dignified way for him to behave. And one leading columnist who pointed this out uh and that you know there's always as people have been saying there's always there's always a quote um but one leading columnist
好吧，实际上，我的意思是，这是昨天早上非常被关注的事情。但戈登·布朗。是的。在2010年那个不确定的选举之后，在唐宁街徘徊。试图组建联合政府。试图组建联合政府。而且有一种轻微的感觉，这不是他表现的一种体面的方式。而一位指出这一点的领先专栏作家，嗯，而且你知道，总是有，正如人们所说，总是有，总是有引语，嗯，但一位领先的专栏作家
who pointed this out was um was uh boris johnson who wrote in the telegraph about gordon brown's refusal to leave the whole thing is unbelievable as i write these words gordon brown is still holed up in downing street he is like some illegal settler in the sinai desert lashing himself to the radiator or like david brent haunting the office in that excruciating episode where he refuses to acknowledge that he's been sacked isn't there someone the queen's private secretary the nice policeman whose job it is to tell him that the game is over so i think we should take a break at this point and dominic when we come back perhaps you could put this uh in the context of british politics okay jolly good i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host
指出这一点的是，嗯，是，嗯，鲍里斯·约翰逊，他在《每日电讯报》上写了关于戈登·布朗拒绝离开的文章，“整件事令人难以置信，当我写下这些话时，戈登·布朗仍然躲在唐宁街。他就像西奈沙漠中的非法定居者，把自己绑在散热器上，或者像大卫·布伦特在那个令人痛苦的剧集中困扰办公室，拒绝承认他被解雇了。难道没有一个人，女王的私人秘书，那个负责告诉他游戏结束的好警察吗？”所以我认为我们应该在这一点上休息一下，多米尼克，当我们回来时，也许你可以把这个，嗯，放在英国政治的背景下。好的，非常好。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持
the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works Hello, welcome back to our boris special um we are recording this on um thursday morning a few hours after the resignation of boris johnson as uh well leader of the conservative party uh not not as prime minister uh he's trying to cling on by the time you listen to this you may have gone as prime minister as well um so dominic um you wrote a fabulous essay for unheard un h-e-r-d uh a couple days ago on boris johnson as as a political leader and you you essentially you you the figure you compared him to was ronald reagan do you want to just just kind of tease that out for people well i think what's easier to forget now because boris johnson is obviously widely
《娱乐的真相》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。你好，欢迎回到我们的鲍里斯特辑，嗯，我们是在，嗯，周四上午录制这个的，在鲍里斯·约翰逊辞职几个小时后，嗯，作为，嗯，保守党领袖，嗯，不是作为首相，嗯，他试图赖着不走，当你听到这个的时候，你可能已经作为首相也走了，嗯，所以多米尼克，嗯，你为《UnHerd》写了一篇精彩的文章，嗯，几天前，关于鲍里斯·约翰逊作为，嗯，政治领导人，你本质上，你，你比较他的形象是罗纳德·里根，你想，只是，只是稍微梳理一下给人们听吗？好吧，我认为现在更容易忘记的是，因为鲍里斯·约翰逊显然被广泛地
he still has fans by the way and some of the people listening to this podcast may well be great admirers of boris johnson but i think it's fair to a fair guess that a larger proportion are not and indeed that some of our listeners actively loathe and despise him. I would say that if we'd done this podcast in 2015 or 2014, that probably wouldn't have been the case. Boris Johnson back then was seen as obviously a comic figure, a sort of joker, but he was also, I would say, pretty clearly on the more liberal wing of the conservative party sort of one nation tory a very live and let live and and he was renowned for his
他仍然有粉丝，顺便说一句，听这个播客的一些人可能确实是鲍里斯·约翰逊的崇拜者，但我认为这是一个公平的猜测，更大比例的人不是，事实上，我们的一些听众积极地厌恶和鄙视他。我会说，如果我们是在2015年或2014年做这个播客，那可能就不会是这种情况了。当时的鲍里斯·约翰逊被视为显然是一个喜剧人物，一种小丑，但他也是，我会说，很清楚地在保守党的更自由派别，一种“一个国家”的托利党，非常“活在当下”，而且他以他的
sort of jolly upbeat sort of you know gag a minute kind of personality and he was of course mayor of london and i often i used to think whether the analogy actually might be with ronald reagan in the u.s because of course reagan was governor of california so like london a kind of quite a you know as a liberal state uh he proved quite a pragmatic governor some people obviously thought he was terrible just like some people thought boris was a terrible mayor. But Reagan associated himself with a very sort of seasoned, experienced, cunning team who made it work while he went and gave the speeches. And he'd been an actor before that. He'd been an actor, of course. And he was brilliant at speechmaking, at meeting the people, at communicating, just as Boris Johnson owes his political career to television, to joking on television, on TV panel shows and so on.
嗯，快乐、乐观、嗯，你知道，每分钟一个笑话的个性而闻名，他当然是伦敦市长，我经常，我过去常想，这个类比实际上是否可能是美国的罗纳德·里根，因为当然，里根是加利福尼亚州长，所以像伦敦一样，一种相当，嗯，你知道，作为一个自由派州，嗯，他证明是一个相当务实的州长，有些人显然认为他很糟糕，就像有些人认为鲍里斯是一个糟糕的市长。但里根把自己与一个非常，嗯，经验丰富、狡猾的团队联系在一起，他们让它运作，而他去发表讲话。而且他之前是一名演员。他当然是一名演员。而且他在演讲、会见人民、沟通方面非常出色，就像鲍里斯·约翰逊把他的政治生涯归功于电视、在电视上开玩笑、在电视小组节目上等等一样。
And so in some ways, I think, I mean, this thing about Fortuna being Fortuna's plaything, the role for which fate seemed to have cast Boris Johnson, if he was ever to be a frontline politician, was of an optimistic, sunny people pleaser. You know, somebody who was never happier than when delivering good news, giving upbeat, patriotic speeches. And in some ways, the question is, why didn't he do that as prime minister? Why didn't he model himself on Reagan in the White House? So when Reagan came in January 1981,
所以从某些方面来看，我认为，嗯，关于命运是命运的玩物这件事，命运似乎为鲍里斯·约翰逊安排的角色，如果他曾经要成为一名一线政治家，那就是一个乐观、阳光、讨好人民的人。你知道，一个当传递好消息、发表乐观、爱国演讲时最快乐的人。而且从某些方面来看，问题是，为什么他没有作为首相那样做？为什么他没有在白宫把自己塑造成里根？所以当里根在1981年1月上任时，
lots of people, you know, hadn't voted for him and said, oh, he's just an actor. He's an airhead. He doesn't know anything. But actually, Reagan surrounded himself with James Baker and George Shultz and Al Haig and Casper Weinberger and all these people who actually knew how Washington worked, who were not showmen and kind of knew how to work the machine. Well, Reagan was the front man. So the question is, why didn't Boris Johnson do that? Why didn't he? And I guess there are two reasons. One, which you mentioned to me before we started recording which was events so covid made it impossible didn't it for him to as you said he he wanted to be charles ii but he became oliver crumwell yeah banning fun and as somebody who was a sort of lifelong funster that was obviously counter to his instincts but i also
很多人，你知道，没有投票给他，说，哦，他只是一个演员。他是一个空头。他什么都不知道。但实际上，里根把自己包围在詹姆斯·贝克、乔治·舒尔茨、阿尔·黑格、卡斯帕·温伯格和所有这些真正知道华盛顿如何运作的人身边，他们不是表演者，而且，嗯，知道如何运作机器。好吧，里根是门面。所以问题是，为什么鲍里斯·约翰逊没有那样做？为什么他没有？而且我猜有两个原因。一个，你在我们开始录音前向我提到的，那就是事件，所以新冠疫情使它变得不可能，不是吗，让他像你所说的那样，他，他想成为查理二世，但他成为了奥利弗·克伦威尔，是的，禁止娱乐，而且作为一个终身的娱乐者，这显然违背了他的本能，但我还
think that that's sort of the to go back to the sort of the Greek tragedy element, which obviously people who despise Boris Johnson will think is completely overblown. Isn't there an argument, Tom, that in the very act of securing power, and the real key to that was toppling David Cameron,
认为，嗯，那，嗯，回到那种希腊悲剧元素，这显然鄙视鲍里斯·约翰逊的人会认为完全被夸大了。汤姆，难道没有一种论点吗，在获得权力的那一刻，而那真正的关键是推翻大卫·卡梅伦，
in the act of securing power, he destroyed the very, he made it impossible for himself to play the part for which he'd been preparing. Because he destroyed Cameron and won ultimately in the long run, the premiership by making himself the figurehead for the Brexit campaign. Exactly. Exactly.
在获得权力的那一刻，他摧毁了，他使自己不可能扮演他一直在准备的角色。因为他摧毁了卡梅伦，并最终在长期内赢得了首相职位，通过使自己成为脱欧运动的领头羊。完全正确。完全正确。
Because he made himself the figurehead for the Brexit campaign, a political movement that actually he, in some ways, he wasn't really that much in sympathy with. So much more protectionist, harder edged, obviously more people on the sort of the right of the Tory party, which is where he didn't really belong in policy terms, I would say. You see, I think that's another way in which he's a slightly Roman figure, is that the Romans weren't ideological in that sense.
因为他使自己成为脱欧运动的领头羊，一个实际上他，在某些方面，他并不是那么同情的一场政治运动。更多保护主义，更强硬，显然更多的人在，嗯，托利党的右翼，那是他在政策方面并不真正属于的地方，我会说。你看，我认为这是他稍微有点罗马式人物的另一种方式，就是罗马人在那个意义上不是意识形态化的。
They didn't have kind of programs. Right. They, you know, politics was like kind of, you know, it was eddies and a river that you try and catch to perceive the wind in the willows. Which is obviously what he was. Which is what he did. I mean, I agree. People say that, you know, he has no real principles and no real convictions. But I think that, you that's you could say the same
他们没有那种，嗯，纲领。对。他们，你知道，政治就像一种，你知道，它是河流中的漩涡，你试图捕捉以感知柳林中的风。这显然就是他。这就是他所做的。我的意思是，我同意。人们说，你知道，他没有真正的原则和真正的信念。但我认为，那，那是，你可以说同样的话
for roman politicians yeah and that was his political identity there wasn't it and i think what by doing that he made it impossible for him ever to play this sort of optimistic jolly people pleaser because half the audience or at least 48 of the audience would always loathe him but dominate and would never forgive him that's i'm sure absolutely but that the 52 i mean that proved enough for him to win a massive majority and you could say that um you know he he was able to appeal well to wakefield and to honiton and tibetan to the two um seat in the north the red wall the seat in the south the kind of the blue wall. So traditionally Labour seats that had moved to the Conservatives. Yeah.
对于罗马政治家，是的，而且那是他的政治身份，不是吗？而且我认为通过那样做，他使自己不可能永远扮演这种乐观、快乐、讨好人民的人，因为一半的观众，或者至少48%的观众会永远厌恶他，但多米尼克，而且永远不会原谅他。那，我确定绝对是，但那52%，我的意思是，那证明足以让他赢得巨大的多数，而且你可以说，嗯，他，他能够很好地吸引韦克菲尔德和霍尼顿和蒂弗顿，那两个，嗯，北部的席位，红墙，南部的席位，那种蓝墙。所以传统上转向保守党的工党席位。是的。
And traditional Conservative seats in the south that he did appeal to both. And that's what won him his majority. He did. He clearly he's lost in a sense. He's lost. Well, not in a sense. I mean, he has lost a lot of backing in both those regions. Yeah.
以及南部的传统保守党席位，他确实吸引了两者。而那赢得了他的多数。他确实。他显然，他在某种意义上。他输了。好吧，不是在某种意义上。我的意思是，他在那两个地区都失去了很多支持。是的。
And that's what that is where i think kovid comes in because i i think he was as a political figure peculiarly unsuited to dealing with kovid i mean i do think he i think it would be insane to deny that he was an incredibly talented politician i mean he well it sounds like campaigner yeah but winning campaigns and elections is a key part of being a politician isn't it right and getting to the top and and he was very very good at that very very effective at that he you know he won re-election as mayor of london yes he did a cosmopolitan liberal multi-ethnic city so clearly he he he was a man of considerable political ability. But I think that COVID was just something he was spectacularly unsuited to dealing with.
而且这就是我认为新冠疫情介入的地方，因为我，我，我认为他作为一个政治人物，特别不适合处理新冠疫情。我的意思是，我确实认为他，我认为否认他是一位非常有天赋的政治家是疯狂的，我的意思是，他，嗯，听起来像竞选者，是的，但赢得竞选和选举是成为政治家的关键部分，不是吗？对，而且到达顶峰，而且他非常非常擅长那个，非常非常有效，他，你知道，他赢得了伦敦市长的连任，是的，他做到了，一个国际化、自由、多民族的城市，所以显然他，他，他是一个具有相当政治能力的人。但我认为新冠疫情只是他特别不适合处理的事情。
It required an ability to convey a sense of compassion. It required an attention to detail. It required a willingness to kind of knuckle down and basically to live a kind of solitary existence because you know you hold up in downing street which i'm sure it explains all the kind of the mad cake parties and things you can't be having these terrible these awful looking parts i mean actually to dignify them with the word parties is if i went to a path if someone invites me to a party and it was rishi Sunak standing there all guilty with a paper cup and Prosecco. Yeah, I'd be absolutely gutted.
这需要一种传达同情心的能力。这需要对细节的关注。这需要一种能够沉下心来，基本上过着一种孤独生活的能力，因为你知道你被困在唐宁街，我相信这解释了所有那些疯狂的蛋糕派对之类的事情，你不能举办这些糟糕的、看起来很可怕的派对，我的意思是，如果我被邀请去参加一个派对，而里希·苏纳克站在那里，手里拿着纸杯和普罗塞克酒，看起来很内疚，如果我真的把它们称为派对，那简直是对“派对”这个词的侮辱。是的，我会感到非常失望。
But I think more than that, I think that COVID has, I think Britain, I think the entire global economy is suffering from long COVID. Yeah, of course it is. Of course it is. I think to deal with that requires talents and qualities that Johnson massively does not possess. Well, Tom, I think there's a couple of points to make there. So one of them is events, dear boy events, as Harold Macmillan famously said in the 1950s, are the challenge for any political leader. So you sort of hear this with people with with politicians they'll often say in their defense well i've been very unfortunate because you know events have ganged up on me and these but i mean that's the nature of the job when you when you move into the it is when you go behind that desk you know things are going to happen there will be wars there will be
但我认为不仅如此，我认为新冠疫情，我认为英国，我认为整个全球经济都在遭受“长新冠”的折磨。是的，当然是这样。当然是这样。我认为要处理这个问题，需要约翰逊完全不具备的才能和素质。嗯，汤姆，我认为这里有几点需要说明。其中之一是“事件，亲爱的孩子，事件”，正如哈罗德·麦克米伦在20世纪50年代那句名言所说，这是任何政治领导人面临的挑战。所以你经常会听到政客们为自己辩护说，好吧，我非常不幸，因为你知道，事件联合起来对付我，但我的意思是，这就是这份工作的本质，当你搬进那个办公室，当你坐在那张桌子后面时，你知道事情会发生，会有战争，会有
crises there will be economic shocks that is the absolute and if you're very lucky if you're very very lucky actually Tony Blair is a very good example I think of somebody who was generally very lucky had an economic a run of kind of calm waters no storm the storms the Antonine piece yeah exactly there were storms I mean were storms. I mean, 9-11, I mean, his own decision to invade Iraq. But economically, he had fantastically plain sailing. Any prime minister in the early 2020s would have had difficulties, but that is the nature of the job. I mean, Franklin Roosevelt in America in the 30s, say, Asquith or Chamberlain or Churchill, who obviously faced the worst crises of all. I actually think that Johnson is quite well suited to dealing with, you know, wars. I think he's had quite a good invasion of Ukraine. Yeah, but that's because he doesn't have to organise anything. Exactly. But he can make the right guess. And also, to give him credit, you know, he has been,
危机，会有经济冲击，这是绝对的。如果你非常幸运，如果你真的非常非常幸运——事实上，托尼·布莱尔就是一个很好的例子，我认为他是一个通常非常幸运的人，他经历了一段经济上的平静水域，没有风暴，没有安东尼时代的和平——是的，完全正确，确实有风暴。我的意思是，9·11事件，我的意思是，他自己入侵伊拉克的决定。但在经济上，他经历了一段非常平稳的航程。20世纪20年代初的任何一位首相都会遇到困难，但这就是这份工作的本质。我的意思是，美国的富兰克林·罗斯福在30年代，或者阿斯奎斯、张伯伦或丘吉尔，他们显然面临着最严重的危机。我实际上认为约翰逊非常适合处理，你知道，战争。我认为他在乌克兰入侵事件上表现得相当不错。是的，但那是因为他不需要组织任何事情。完全正确。但他能做出正确的猜测。而且，值得称赞的是，你知道，他一直，
he was kind of ahead of the curve with that. He was alert to it. So that is something I think that he got right. I just think that a massive public health crisis, I suspect he has no interest in hospitals or doctors or, you know, vaccines. It's just, I think, completely leaves leaves him cold i think he's just not interested i think there's another element to this which is that a uh a really successful high-end politician i mean that thing about reagan politicians are actors they are public performers
他在那方面走在了前面。他对此很警觉。所以我认为这是他做对的一件事。我只是认为，对于一场大规模的公共卫生危机，我怀疑他对医院、医生或，你知道，疫苗毫无兴趣。我认为这完全让他感到冷漠，我认为他只是不感兴趣。我认为这还有另一个因素，那就是一个真正成功的顶级政客——我的意思是关于里根的那件事，政客就是演员，他们是公众表演者。
i mean that was true must have been true in the roman world i mean it obviously was true in the roman world one of the most famous bits of Roman political theatre, Mark Antony giving Caesar's funeral oration, is pure performance, isn't it? But I think a good politician is capable of playing more than one part. So Boris was clearly very good at playing a particular part, which is the kind of roguish mountebank. And British politics has been littered with those. So we've talked about that didn't we in our episode on how prime ministers fall and you drew analogies with disraeli with yeah disraeli
我的意思是，这在罗马世界一定也是真的，我的意思是，这在罗马世界显然是真的。罗马政治戏剧中最著名的片段之一，马克·安东尼发表凯撒的葬礼演说，纯粹是表演，不是吗？但我认为一个好的政客有能力扮演不止一个角色。所以鲍里斯显然非常擅长扮演一个特定的角色，那就是那种流氓骗子。英国政坛充斥着这样的人。所以我们谈论过这一点，不是吗？在我们关于首相如何下台的那一集里，你把他们与迪斯雷利进行了类比，是的，迪斯雷利。
lloyd george blair to some extent um harold mcmillan was the kind of actor i mean palmerston in that unheard piece that you mentioned i quoted karl marx about palmerstonston. So Karl Marx said of Palmerston, if not a good statesman of all work, he's at least a good... Not a very good accent, Dominic. I'm not doing your terrible Karl Marx accent. Because I mean... Go on. I mean, people will just have to imagine that in your hair flick. In your hair flick.
劳合·乔治，布莱尔在某种程度上，嗯，哈罗德·麦克米伦是那种演员，我的意思是帕默斯顿，在你提到的那段未听过的片段中，我引用了卡尔·马克思关于帕默斯顿的话。所以卡尔·马克思谈到帕默斯顿说，如果不是一个全能的好政治家，他至少是一个好的……多米尼克，你的口音不太好。我不会模仿你那糟糕的卡尔·马克思口音。因为我的意思是……继续。我的意思是，人们只能想象你甩头发的样子。在你甩头发的时候。
Well, your Clouseau. I thought that was very Clouseau, your Karl Marx. So Karl Marx said, in my voice, if not a good statesman of all work, he is at least a good actor of all work. He succeeds in the comic as in the heroic. He's not a first-class orator, but an accomplished debater.
嗯，你的克鲁索探长。我觉得你的卡尔·马克思非常像克鲁索。所以卡尔·马克思用我的声音说，如果不是一个全能的好政治家，他至少是一个全能的好演员。他在喜剧和英雄主义方面都取得了成功。他不是一流的演说家，但却是一位出色的辩论家。
And it goes on, being an exceedingly happy joker, he ingratiates himself with everybody. Never losing his temper, he imposes on an impassioned antagonist when unable to master a subject he knows how to play with it if wanting in general views he's always ready to weave a web of elegant generalities and this sort of persona for Palmerston were very well because there's a lovely story about him going with a speaker of the house of commons to the great
他继续说道，作为一个极其快乐的笑话家，他讨好每一个人。他从不发脾气，当无法掌握某个主题时，他会强加给激情的对手，他知道如何玩弄它；如果缺乏宏观视野，他总是准备好编织一张优雅的概括之网。这种帕默斯顿的形象非常有效，因为有一个关于他与下议院议长一起去参加伟大的
exhibition in 1851 and the speaker says as we walked along i could gauge the popularity of lord palmerston the moment he came in sight throughout the whole building men and women young and old at once were struck as if by an electric shock lord palmerston here's lord palmerston bravo hurrah lord palmerston forever and so it went on throughout the whole building but that's like johnson at the olympics that is johnson at the olympics that's precisely the point he was an entertainer he was a a showman as pal Palmerston was, as Disraeli was, as Lloyd George was. But all of those three men all had other parts that they played. So Palmerston, you know, he's not just the sort of the showman at home.
1851年博览会的美妙故事，议长说，当我们走过时，我可以衡量帕默斯顿勋爵的受欢迎程度，他一出现，整个建筑里的男人和女人，年轻人和老年人，立刻就像被电击了一样，帕默斯顿勋爵在这里，帕默斯顿勋爵，万岁，欢呼，帕默斯顿勋爵万岁，整个建筑里都是这样。但这就像奥运会上的约翰逊，那就是奥运会上的约翰逊，这正是重点，他是一个艺人，他是一个表演者，就像帕默斯顿一样，就像迪斯雷利一样，就像劳合·乔治一样。但这三个人都有他们扮演的其他角色。所以帕默斯顿，你知道，他不仅仅是国内的表演者。
He's also the imperialist abroad. Disraeli is also a reformer. He's also the romantic novelist. He's also the imperialist abroad. Disraeli is also a reformer. He's also the romantic novelist. He's also all these other things. Lloyd George, he's an absolute philanderer and disgraceful man, but he's also a passionate reformer. He's also a brilliant committee chairman who, you know, he combines the Michael Gove and the Boris Johnson, if you like. He can do all the nuts and bolts. And that's true of, I mean, Tony Blair could play different parts. Margaret Thatcher could in America. I mean, Reagan could play different parts, obviously,
他也是国外的帝国主义者。迪斯雷利也是一位改革家。他也是浪漫小说家。他也是国外的帝国主义者。迪斯雷利也是一位改革家。他也是浪漫小说家。他也是所有这些其他东西。劳合·乔治，他是一个彻头彻尾的浪子和可耻的人，但他也是一位充满激情的改革家。他也是一位出色的委员会主席，你知道，他结合了迈克尔·戈夫和鲍里斯·约翰逊的特点，如果你愿意的话。他能处理所有的琐事。这对于，我的意思是托尼·布莱尔可以扮演不同的角色。玛格丽特·撒切尔在美国也可以。我的意思是，里根显然可以扮演不同的角色，
and he had done all his life. Roosevelt could. I think Boris, if he was an actor with a casting agency, there's only one part he can play. He can't do anything else. And I think that's where he was found out. Well, and that was the whole problem with COVID, because he couldn't do anything else and i think that's where he was found out well that and that was the whole problem with covid because he couldn't he couldn't stand there and you know he'd say i you know my thoughts are with everyone who's you know suffering and everything but he just couldn't make it sound
他一生都在这样做。罗斯福也可以。我认为鲍里斯，如果他是一个有选角代理公司的演员，他只能扮演一个角色。他做不了别的。我认为这就是他被发现的地方。嗯，这就是新冠疫情的全部问题所在，因为他做不了别的，我认为这就是他被发现的地方，嗯，这就是新冠疫情的全部问题所在，因为他不能，他不能站在那里，你知道，他会说，我，你知道，我的心与每一个，你知道，正在受苦的人同在，等等，但他就是不能让它听起来
plausible sounded like he was going to have a kind even even though he himself had very you know almost died of it even after that he couldn't really yeah it's interesting how even after that because that's sort of completely forgotten now isn't it that he was wasn't he he he went and he was you know he was in trouble with it but that's disappeared from our national memory because it doesn't and he doesn't really play on that himself because he hates playing the victim um a different with a different political persona that might loom larger in that sort of sense of them yeah joey our producer is sending us a message to say is he the last prime minister that the general public would most want to have a pint with i mean that
可信，听起来好像他要有一种，即使他自己也差点死于这种病，即使在那之后，他仍然不能真正地……是的，有趣的是，即使在那之后，因为那现在已经被完全遗忘了，不是吗？他曾经，不是吗？他去了，他，你知道，他因为这个陷入了困境，但那已经从我们的国家记忆中消失了，因为它没有，而且他自己并没有真正利用这一点，因为他讨厌扮演受害者，嗯，如果是一个不同的政治形象，那在他们的那种感觉中可能会显得更重要。是的，我们的制片人乔伊给我们发了一条信息，问他是不是普通大众最不想一起喝品脱啤酒的首相？我的意思是那个
having the pint thing they have the same thing in america they use the same formula when they're talking about politicians and i think it really matters i mean nobody wanted to have a drink with theresa may did they probably not really with carrie star mean, nobody wanted to have a drink with Theresa May, did they? Probably not really with Keir Starmer either. Would you go for a drink with Jeremy Corbyn? No, probably not. But you would go for it. I mean, actually, I was talking to somebody the other week who knows Boris Johnson and has known him for a long time
喝品脱啤酒的事情，在美国也有同样的情况，他们在谈论政客时使用同样的公式，我认为这真的很重要。我的意思是，没有人想和特蕾莎·梅喝一杯，对吧？可能真的没有，和基尔·斯塔默……我的意思是，没有人想和特蕾莎·梅喝一杯，对吧？可能和基尔·斯塔默也没有。你会和杰里米·科尔宾去喝一杯吗？不，可能不会。但你会去。我的意思是，事实上，我上周和一位认识鲍里斯·约翰逊并且认识他很久的人谈过，
and he said to me, he was telling me everything that was wrong with him. You know, he went through the whole list of all the failings and all these kinds of things. And then he said, the weird thing about him is he is obviously a terrible man in all these different ways but if he came in now and he pulled up a chair at this table he would be such good company and we would have such a tremendous time and he would be so fun to be with and that's the sort of the paradox of him. Well, that's what people responded to. People clearly sense that. Yeah, I think that's why he became one mayor,
他对我说，他告诉我他身上所有的问题。你知道，他列举了所有的缺点和所有这些事情。然后他说，关于他奇怪的事情是，他在所有这些方面显然是一个糟糕的人，但如果他现在进来，在这张桌子旁拉一把椅子坐下，他会是一个非常好的伙伴，我们会度过一段非常美妙的时光，和他在一起会非常有趣，这就是他的悖论。嗯，这就是人们所回应的。人们显然感觉到了这一点。是的，我认为这就是他成为市长的原因，
you know, the mayor and all that. So two questions for you before we go. The first is, has he inflicted serious damage on the idea of the Mos Mayorum, the idea of the unwritten british constitution being governed by convention by a kind of understanding that politicians of all shapes and sizes will be governed by an accepted morality an accepted sense of what chaps should do that kind of thing has he has he inflicted serious damage on that or that's an
你知道，市长什么的。所以在我们结束之前有两个问题要问你。第一个是，他是否对“Mos Maiorum”（祖宗之法）的概念造成了严重损害，即英国不成文宪法由惯例治理，由一种理解治理，即各种各样的政客都将受到公认的道德、公认的“绅士应该做什么”的感觉的约束，他是否对这一点造成了严重损害，还是这是一个
excellent question has the fact that britain's unwritten constitution has in the long run withstood him kind of you know evacuated him as it were voided him um showing that that it's still functioning um and the second question is will he be seen as a historically significant prime minister oh that's they're two brilliant questions tom you should ask questions more often um so the first one i would probably say some listeners may disagree with this but but i think um i think the conventions are intact um i think he has obviously tested them and he's broken a lot of them but as you say the fact that he's been evacuated by the system it's very telling isn't it that um in the end of virtually every single senior conservative either came out against him or just stayed silent and refused to
极好的问题。英国不成文宪法从长远来看经受住了他的考验，某种程度上，你知道，把他“排泄”了，或者说清除了他，这是否表明它仍然在运作？第二个问题是，他会被视为一位具有历史意义的首相吗？哦，那是两个精彩的问题，汤姆，你应该多问问题。所以第一个问题，我可能会说——一些听众可能不同意这一点——但我认为，嗯，我认为惯例是完好无损的。我认为他显然考验了它们，他打破了其中的许多，但正如你所说，他被系统“排泄”的事实非常能说明问题，不是吗？几乎每一位资深保守党人都要么站出来反对他，要么保持沉默并拒绝
support him and the ones who did support him were the ones who would only ever have got a job. Exactly. I mean, he was left at this point. I mean, if Nadine Doris and Jacob Rees-Mulgay listeners to this podcast, I'd be quite surprised. But also, you know, I think it's nice to be inclusive to our listeners. So I apologize to them for what I'm about to say. But I mean, if these two otter clowns are the only people
支持他，而那些支持他的人是那些只会得到一份工作的人。完全正确。我的意思是，他在这一点上被抛弃了。我的意思是，如果纳丁·多里斯和雅各布·里斯-莫格是这个播客的听众，我会感到非常惊讶。但同时，你知道，我认为对我们的听众保持包容是很好的。所以我为我接下来要说的话向他们道歉。但我的意思是，如果这两个水獭小丑是唯一支持你的人，而党内各个派系的其他人，从史蒂夫·贝克那样的自由意志主义右翼，到杰里米·亨特那样的保守党留欧左翼，人们有如此多样化的观点，都站出来反对你，说你打破了惯例，你必须离开，那么显然有什么地方出了问题。而且我认为实际上，很难……他被如此公开地羞辱，事实上，汤姆，他因为打破惯例、撒谎而被羞辱，你知道，他派部长们去说那些会……而且他显然激怒了他们。有人说，我今天在理发店理发，我们聊到，你知道，他有点说，嗯，政客们，他们都一样，不是吗？他们
you have left supporting you and everybody else on on every wing of the party so from Steve Baker on the kind of libertarian right to Jeremy Hunt on the kind of remainer left of the Tory party people have such diverse views are coming out against you and saying you've broken the conventions you have to go then clearly something is wrong and i think actually it's hard to the fact that he's been punished as it were so publicly humiliated actually tom he's been humiliated for breaking the conventions for lying for you know he's sending out ministers to say things that would and he's clearly infuriated them somebody's that the i was having my hair cut today in the bar and i were chatting about you know he sort of said well politicians they're all the same aren't they they
他们都是骗子，所有这些事情，这当然是人们总是说的，但实际上在某些方面，过去几天发生的事情表明，无论你怎么看政客，他们都不是他们自己所想的那样。我的意思是，他们中的很多人谈论过那些故事，像贾维德谈论过他们的正直。现在，你可能认为，或者听众可能认为，哦，他们本来就没有正直，但他们显然认为自己有。而且，你知道，首相已经，已经制造了这一点，或者已经玷污了它。所以我认为实际上，惯例，它们仍然，大多数，绝大多数人显然仍然相信这些惯例，所以我认为这与2021年1月6日在美国发生的事情不可同日而语。嗯，不，好吧，那绝对不是。我的意思是，我的意思是，对吧，你知道，人们某种程度上一直把唐纳德·特朗普和鲍里斯·约翰逊进行比较，我实际上从来没有觉得这是对的，因为我认为他们是完全不同的政治人物。我的意思是，他们都有金发，他们都是民粹主义者，正如你所说的关于堕胎辩论，英国不是美国，
all they're all liars and all this sort of thing which is of course what people always say but actually in some ways the what's happened in the last few days shows whatever you think of politicians they're not what what they think of themselves they i mean they've a lot of them have talked those stories like javid have talked about their integrity. Now, you may well think, or the listeners may think, oh, they've got no integrity anyway, but they clearly think they do. And that, you know, the Prime Minister has, has produced that or has tarnished it. So I think actually, the conventions, they still a lot, most of them them the vast majority still clearly believe in those conventions so i don't think it's analogous to what happened on the 6th of january 2021 in america um no well that's where absolutely not i mean i mean right you know people are sort of have always made this comparison between donald trump and boris johnson i've actually never ever thought was right because i thought they're such totally different political personalities I mean they both got blonde hair and they're both populists and as you said about um the abortion debate Britain is not America
不是所有事情都必须通过美国的棱镜来看待，而且这并不是真的，不，这一直是在测试宪法的极限。我还会提出许多听众会认为是某种疯狂观点的看法，但我实际上认为，每个国家目前都在遭受新冠疫情的后遗症，能源价格上涨的影响意味着每个国家都在经历一个可怕的阶段，我认为那些不符合时代严重性的领导人，你知道，离开，让别人接手，这是正确且恰当的，我认为从这个意义上说，事实上，英国
not everything has to be seen through an American prism and and this and this is not really like no this is this has been a this has been about the testing of the limits of the constitution I would I would also make what what i'm sure many listeners will regard as a kind of insane perspective but i i i actually think that every country at the moment is massively hurting the after effects of covid and the impact of uh energy price rises means every country is going through a terrible stage and i think that it's kind of right and proper that that leaders who don't measure up to the the gravity of the times you know go and someone else be brought in and i think in that sense actually the british
宪法在某种程度上表明它是有效的。嗯，我的意思是，即使在最基本的意义上它也在运作。他失去了下议院的信任。他必须走。就这么简单。但我同意你的看法，一位不同的首相。我认为还有一件事会很好，过去七年，六、七年里，英国政坛有很多热度。我认为温度稍微降低一点会很好，
constitution is kind of showing that it works. Well, I mean, it's working even in the most very basic sense. He's lost the confidence of the House of Commons. He's got to go. It's as simple as that. But I agree with you, a different prime minister. What would also be good, I think, there's been a lot of heat in British politics in the last seven years, six, seven years. I think a slightly lower temperature would be nice would
会对英国有好处。但同样，我的意思是，作为对那件事的反应，嗯，是的，同样，你知道，英国一直在经历一个前所未有的动荡时期，国外的视角是，你知道，到底出了什么问题？一切似乎都在出错。但你同样可以说，这很好地反映了英国的民主，因为实际上，每个国家都应该经历一段可怕的时期，每个国家都面临着难以置信的压力、紧张和挑战，以及某种存在主义的问题。而且在某种意义上，事实上，嗯，你知道，我们举行了这么多次选举，这么多奇怪的公投，
would be good for britain but again i mean in reaction to that um yeah again you know britain has been going through a unprecedentedly tumultuous time um and the perspective from abroad is you know what on earth is going wrong everything seems to be going wrong but you again you could say that this reflects quite well on british democracy because actually every country should be going through a terrible time every country is facing incredible stresses and strains and challenges and kind of existential questions uh and in a sense the fact that that um you know we've had so many elections so many weird referendums,
我的意思是，各种疯狂的事情到处发生。我的意思是，疯狂的事情应该发生，因为我们正生活在疯狂的时代。汤姆，这是顶级的评论，但我实际上完全同意你的看法。我完全同意你的看法。我认为一个喧闹、多彩、混乱的民主更好，只要温度，只要那种，你知道，只要温度没有上升太多，只要它没有达到1640年代那种程度，我们不想要
I mean, all kinds of mad shit happening left, right and centre. I mean, mad shit should be happening because we're living through the age of mad shit. Tom, this is top punditry, but actually I completely agree with you. I completely agree with you. I think a rambunctious, colourful, chaotic democracy is better as long as the temperature long as the sort of you know as long as the temperature doesn't rise too much as long as it doesn't go for the full 1640s we don't want
那个，对吧，完全正确。但一个疯狂事情发生的喧闹民主，并不是一件坏事。而且我认为人们通常做的对比是，他们说看看英国，有这些可怕的派系和这些荒谬的发展，看看德国，有如此美妙的稳定性，所有这些事情。而且当然，我们在英国很容易看向海峡对岸的德国，说，哦，这不是很令人钦佩吗？另一方面，你看，我的意思是安格拉·默克尔，我们做了一个关于安格拉·默克尔和德国总理及其遗产的完整播客。我的意思是，那现在看起来相当可疑，那种自满停滞的时期，如果你愿意的话。
that right exactly but a rambunctious democracy in which crazy things happen um is is not a bad thing and i think the contrast that people classically make is they say look at britain with these sort of terrible clans and these ludicrous developments and look at germany with such wonderful stability and all of these kinds of things um and of course it's very tempting for us in britain to look at to look across the the channel at germany and say oh isn't this admirable and stuff on the other hand you look i mean angela merkel who we did a whole podcast about angela merkel and German chancellors and her legacy. I mean, that looks pretty dodgy now, that period of kind of complacent stagnation, if you like.
以与俄罗斯的北溪协议和对弗拉基米尔·普京的这种事实上的绥靖政策结束。现在这个新家伙看起来像威尔特郡一个小镇的银行经理。没有冒犯的意思，汤姆。她绝对没有任何问题。但是，你知道，谁，同样，拥有看起来相当可疑的记录。你可以争论关于俄罗斯的问题，你可以争论说实际上一点喧闹的民主，更多的国家可以从中受益。而且在某种程度上，事实上它是滑稽和混乱的等等，我不认为那是必要的。
Ending with the Nord Stream deal with Russia and this sort of virtual appeasement of Vladimir Putin. Now the new guy looks like he's a bank manager from a small town of Wiltshire. No offence, Tom. Absolutely nothing wrong with her. But, you know, who's, again, got what looks like a pretty dodgy record. You could argue on Russia, you could argue that actually a bit of a rambunctious democracy that more countries could do with it. And in a way, the fact that it is farcical and chaotic and whatnot, I don't think that's necessary.
这是摄政时期，不是吗？一件可怕的事情。这就是它。是的。我的意思是，约翰逊是一个摄政王式的人物。18世纪的人，汤姆，会看看现在发生的事情，他们会说，这是绝对标准的。这完全没问题。
It's regency, isn't it? A terrible thing. That's what it is. Yeah. I mean, Johnson is a kind of Prince Regent figure. People in the 18th century, Tom, would look at what was happening now and they'd say, this is absolutely standard. This is completely fine.
现在，这就是鲍里斯·约翰逊在历史上的地位。他将作为一个相当短命的首相被载入史册。所以他在那里。我想和张伯伦同一时期，直到今天。是的，他现在和张伯伦在一起。而且我认为很有可能，难道这不会是最美味的讽刺吗，他可能无法达到特蕾莎·梅的任期，那会非常有趣。所以他会被记住吗？
Now, that's Boris Johnson's place in history. He's going to go down as quite a short-lived prime minister. So he's down there. Same time as Chamberlain, I think, to this day. Yeah, he's down there right now with Chamberlain. And I think it's quite possible, and wouldn't this be the most sort of delicious irony, that he may not match Theresa May's time in office, which would be very amusing. So will he be remembered?
我认为他肯定会被记住，因为他是一个人物。而英国，大多数首相，我们已经谈论过很多次了，大多数首相都被彻底地遗忘了。所以谁还记得德比伯爵？谁还记得亚历克·道格拉斯-休姆爵士？没人。坦率地说，40岁以下的人谁还记得哈罗德·威尔逊？或者詹姆斯·卡拉汉。或者詹姆斯，好吧，谁还记得詹姆斯·卡拉汉？谁还记得斯坦利·鲍德温，汤姆？没人，坦率地说，40岁以下的人谁还记得哈罗德·威尔逊或詹姆斯·卡拉汉或詹姆斯，好吧，
I think he definitely will be remembered because he's a character. And British, most prime ministers, we've talked about this so many times, most prime ministers are completely and utterly forgotten. So who remembers the Earl of Derby? Who remembers Sir Alec Douglas Hume? Nobody. Frankly, who under the age of 40 remembers Harold Wilson? Or James Callaghan. Or James, well, who does remember James Callaghan? Who remembers Stanley Baldwin, Tom? nobody frankly who under the age of 40 remembers harold wilson or james callahan or james well
谁还记得詹姆斯，谁还记得斯坦利·鲍德温，汤姆？我很痛苦地说，没人记得。如果你在街上问20个人斯坦利·鲍德温是谁，他们会说他在20世纪50年代初为博尔顿流浪者队效力。他确实有那种声音，嗯，你知道，我认为很少有人记得。撒切尔被记住了，丘吉尔被记住了，也许布莱尔会被记住，卡梅伦不会，梅可能不会。鲍里斯·约翰逊，我认为鲍里斯·约翰逊会被记住为一个人物，他会因为脱欧而被记住，他也可能因为他离职的混乱性质而被记住，但除此之外，他可能因为在新冠疫情期间担任首相而被记住，如果新冠疫情被记住的话。但新冠疫情会被记住吗？我的意思是，有多少人记得
who does remember james who remembers stanley baldwin tom it pains me to say it but nobody does if you ask 20 people in the street who was stanley baldwin they'd say that he played for bolton wanderers in nine in the early 1950s he does have that sound um you know i think very few thatcher is remembered church is remembered maybe Blair will be remembered Cameron no may know Boris Johnson I think Boris Johnson will be remembered as a character he'll be remembered for Brexit and he'll also possibly be remembered for the chaotic nature of his departure but other than that and he may be remembered for being the prime minister during covid if covid is remembered but it will covid remembered i mean how many people remembered the
西班牙流感在新冠疫情爆发之前？我认为这取决于新冠疫情的长期遗产是什么，我认为现在下结论还为时过早，但我的意思是，我们的孙辈会在乎新冠疫情吗？我的意思是，如果长期遗产是，好吧，如果他们回顾并研究，你知道，第三次世界大战的原因是什么？是的，那是对的。好吧，我认为事实的真相是，让我们想象我们的孙辈在学校学习21世纪初的英国历史。他们会带着那种厌倦感，艰难地完成关于卡梅伦时代和紧缩政策等的论文题目，或者特蕾莎·梅及其各种脱欧协议的细节。然后他们会翻过这一页，会有一张鲍里斯·约翰逊毫无疑问地悬挂在那个滑索上，带着他的联合，
spanish flu before covid struck i think it depends what the the long-term legacy of covid is which i think it's too early to tell but i mean will our grandchildren care about covid i i mean if the long-term legacy is that well if they're looking back and studying, you know, what are the causes of the Third World War? Yeah, that's right. Well, I think the truth of the matter is, let's imagine our grandchildren doing British history in the early 21st century at school. And the sort of weariness with which they will plod through the essay questions on the Cameron years and austerity and stuff, or Theresa May and the details of her various Brexit deals. And then they'll turn the page and there'll be a picture of Boris Johnson dangling unquestionably dangling from that zip wire with his union,
杰克旗帜的照片。他们会如释重负地长舒一口气，就像你如果即将学习查尔斯·詹姆斯·福克斯时会说的那样，太棒了，终于有一个好人物了。这会很有趣。你花一周时间研究鲍里斯·约翰逊，这对他来说可能相当不客气，
Jack flags. And they will breathe a colossal sigh of relief much as you would, if you were about to study Charles James Fox and you'd say, great, finally a good character. This is going to be a laugh. You do a week on Boris Johnson and it probably would be quite disobliging to him,
但这会很有趣。现在，他可能不想，我认为在内心深处，他不想作为一个小丑被载入史册。不。他想作为一个伟人被载入史册，不是吗？但那是命运的玩笑。这是命运的玩笑。所以我们应该以一个预测结束。
but it will be fun. Now, he probably didn't want, I think deep down, he didn't want to go down in history as a joker. No. He wanted to go down as a great man, didn't he? But that's Fortuna's joke. It is Fortuna's joke. So we should end with a prediction.
所以你认为，我要让你当场表态，你认为谁会在这个日历年年底担任首相？哦，我以为你会说在本周末，如果是那样的话，我会说是多米尼克·拉布，他是副首相，我认为他会失误。这是一个公平的预测，但你认为谁会在年底担任首相？我不是评论员，多米尼克。
So who do you think, I'm going to put you on the spot, who do you think will be Prime Minister at the end of this calendar year? Oh, I thought you were going to say at the end of this week, in which case I would have said Dominic Raab, who is the Deputy Prime Minister and who I think will slip up that's a fair prediction but who do you think will be Prime Minister at the end of the year I'm no pundit Dominic
我知道你不是，但我让你当场表态。我认为是里希·苏纳克，里希·苏纳克。我不认为会是里希·苏纳克。我认为他表现出了一定程度的尊严，他非常，非常，一定程度的尊严。他太，他非常，非常小。
I know you're not but I'm putting you on the spot I think Rishi Sunak Rishi Sunak I don't think it'll be Rishi Sunak I think he's behaved with a degree of dignity he's very very a degree of dignity. He's too, he's very, very small.
没关系。他太矮了。他可以穿厚底鞋。像萨科齐一样。他看起来像私立学校的男学生代表。好吧，他确实是男学生代表。他是男学生代表。他是温彻斯特的男学生代表。但他看起来像，你知道，他穿着整洁的校服。
Doesn't matter. He's too short. He can wear platform heels. Like Sarkozy. He looks like head boy at the private school. Well, he was the head boy. He was the head boy. He was the head boy of Winchester. But he looks like he's, you know, he's in his smart school uniform.
杰里米·亨特也是男学生代表。他是查特豪斯学校的男学生代表，是吗？嗯，你会期望我对这些人去过哪些学校有稍微强迫性的了解，而且我想我们之前提到过吗？嗯，杰里米·亨特有一个宴会厅，是的，我们提到了，一个弹簧，是的，弹簧宴会厅。我的意思是，你知道，有理由说我们第一位拥有自己宴会厅的首相。好吧，不，我相信他们在18世纪都拥有自己的宴会厅。他把他的妻子误认为是……他把她误认为是一个日本女人。
Jeremy Hunt was also a head boy. He was head boy of Char house was he um you would expect me to have an a slightly obsessive knowledge of which schools all these people went to and i think did we mention this before uh that jeremy hunt has a a ballroom yeah we did a spring yeah springs a spring ballroom i mean you know there's a case for saying that our first prime minister, who owns his own ballroom. Well, no, I'm sure they all owned their own ballrooms back in the 18th century. He mistook his wife for... He mistook her for a Japanese woman.
他不是去中国说，我很高兴来到这里，因为我的妻子是日本人吗？哦，我的意思是，中国人。不，我认为是反过来的，不是吗？他去了日本。是反过来的吗？他说，我的妻子是日本人。不，她不是。我不记得了。是的，但确实有。无论如何，我是说中国人。抱歉。我认为是反过来的，不是吗？他去了日本。是反过来的吗？你说我的妻子是日本人。不，她不是。我不记得了。
Didn't he go to China and he said, I'm delighted to be here because my wife is Japanese. Oh, I mean Chinese. No, I think the other way around, wasn't it? He went to Japan. Was it the other way around? He said, my wife's Japanese. No, she's not. I can't remember. Yes, but there was. Anyway, I'm in Chinese. Sorry. I think the other way around, wasn't it? He went to Japan. Was it the other way around? You said my wife's Japanese. No, she's not. I can't remember.
是的，但确实有。无论如何，那是一个非常有趣的时刻。所以我的预测是本·华莱士。我认为可能是他。我袖子里有一匹黑马。我认为可能是彭妮·莫当特。是吗？嗯，她是一个鲍里斯式的人物，不是吗？
Yes, but there was. Anyway, it was a very entertaining moment. So my prediction is Ben Wallace. I think it might be. I've got a dark horse up my sleeve. I think it might be Penny Mordant. Do you? Well, she's a kind of Boris-esque figure, though, isn't she?
她有点像那种快乐的“随身携带”风格。她参加过跳水比赛，一个真人秀节目。她确实参加过，是的。当她是议员的时候。是的。你看，我不认为会是彭妮·莫当特，因为我认为她太像鲍里斯了。而且我认为英国政治的节奏是圆颅党和骑士党，
She's a kind of jolly carry-on. She took part in a diving competition, a reality show. She did, yes. When she was an MP. Yes. You see, I don't think it would be Penny Maldon, because I think she's too Boris-like. And I think the rhythm of British politics is roundhead cavalier,
圆颅党和骑士党。那么谁是真正的圆颅党？你说谁？苏纳克。苏纳克。他钱太多了。他太有钱了。所以是一个真正的圆颅党。
roundhead cavalier. So who's the real roundhead? Who did you say? Sue Nex. Sue Nex. He's got too much money. He's too rich. So a real roundhead.
有本·华莱士，国防大臣。我认为他的名片基本上就是你。这很无聊。是的，这很无聊。他是一个像这样说话的军人。是的，我的意思是，显然，特蕾莎·梅仍然可以担任。我只是……我曾经写过一篇专栏文章，宣称特蕾莎·梅将在未来十年在英国政坛留下她的印记，你写过吗？我可能仍然是对的。你把那个撤下来吧，嗯，另一个可能在年底突出的黑马当然是，或者当他辞职时谁接替他，这将是巨大的，他会因为什么再次辞职？他吃了可乐还是什么？他吃了咖喱，咖喱什么的，吃了咖喱和啤酒，是的，有人对我说基尔·斯塔默一生中只喝过一次啤酒，讽刺的是，我的意思是，那真的是命运的诅咒，如果，嗯，那唯一的一杯啤酒就是那杯啤酒，所以也许韦斯·斯特里廷，他是接替基尔·斯塔默的布莱尔派候选人，我不知道。我让你说得够久了。
There's Ben Wallace, the Defence Secretary. I think his sort of calling card is basically you. It's very boring. Yeah, it's very boring. He's sort of a military man who talks like this. Yeah, I mean, obviously, Theresa May is still available. I'm just... I once wrote a column proclaiming that theresa may was going to leave
布莱尔主义出来了，汤姆。当然，托尼，托尼仍然。哦，托尼。是的。
her stamp on british politics for a decade did you and i could still be right you have that taken down um well another dark horse for who might be prominent at the end of the year of course is or whoever succeeds him when he resigns which which will be massive bans what would he resign for again did he have a coke or something he had a curry curry or something had a curry and a beer yeah somebody said to me keir starmer's only ever had one beer in his life and the irony i mean that really is fortuna's curse if if um that one beer is the beer so maybe maybe wes streeting uh who is the blairite candidate to succeed keir starmer i don know. I keep you talking long enough.
你，爱德华王子和托尼。布莱尔家族。对。是的。好吧，也许爱德华王子，也许爱德华王子。
The Blairism comes out, Tom. Of course, Tony, Tony's still. Oh, Tony. Yes.
在那，在那重磅炸弹上，我认为我们应该结束这漫无边际的谈话。我认为它一点也不漫无边际。我认为结束这漫无边际的谈话，我认为这是一场绝对的顶级评论展示，一流的评论。《匹兹堡邮报》会对此大加报道，但多米尼克，你知道什么是可怕的
You, Prince Edward and Tony. House Blair. Right. Yeah. Well, maybe Prince Edward, maybe Prince Edward.
是这在一年后仍然会存在。是的，但我的意思是，就像你预测特蕾莎·梅将在未来十年主导英国政坛的文章一样，我想是的，但仍然存在的是我们开场的，我们非常开场的播客，汤姆，关于伟大。好吧，最后一次伟大是最后五分钟都在谈论弗拉基米尔·普京。好吧，我们还没有把它撤下来，不，因为我认为那是一个非常精明的分析，因为他他正试图成为彼得大帝，是的，他现在完全公开了，不是吗？我没有
On that, on that bombshell, I think we should draw this rambling. I think it's been rambling at all. I think draw this rambling I think it's been rambling at all I think it's been an absolute display of top punditry at first class punditry the Pittsburgh Post Gazette will be all over it but Dominic you know what's terrifying
以任何方式道歉，我认为那非常出色，我认为我们绝对说中了。好吧，以这种自我祝贺的语气，所以我们准备了各种各样的好东西，嗯，我们有一整个系列的播客，关于伦敦的历史，嗯，我们有乔治·奥威尔，我们有期待已久的关于，嗯，鸽子的历史及其对世界文明的贡献的一集，而且在周一，多米尼克，我们有什么？我不，我其实不记得了。我们有，我们有岛屿吗？哦，我们有《爱之岛》。好吧，每个人在经历了本周的事件后都会想要振作起来，并找出我们的——你想描述他们吗，汤姆？使用你那久经考验的短语“历史上的帅哥和美女”，找出哪些帅哥和美女
is that this will still be up in a year's time yeah but I mean like your article predicting the truth of a well dominate british politics for a decade i think yes but what's also still up is our opening our very opening podcast tom about greatness well the last great is where the last five minutes are all about vladimir putin well and we haven't taken that down no because i think that was a very shrewd analysis because he he is trying to be peter the great yeah he is well he's he's completely open about it now isn't he i'm not in
会做什么？好吧，所以节目结束时会有四对情侣，他们将接受公众投票，所以你可以决定谁赢得了2022年历史版《爱之岛》。这再令人兴奋不过了，周一播出，千万不要错过。那对梦幻情侣犹大·伊斯卡里奥特和弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫脱颖而出，等着瞧吧。这再令人兴奋不过了，这比政治令人兴奋多了，对吧？再见大家，再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。获取奖励剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听、我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。那是restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的
any way apologizing i think that was excellent i think we were absolutely on the money well on that self-congratulatory note so we have got all kinds of treats lined up uh we've got a whole series of a week of podcasts all about the history of london um we have george orwell we have the long-awaited episode on um the history of pigeons and their contribution to world civilization and on monday dominate what do we have i don't i can't remember actually we have do we have island oh we have love island well everybody will be will want cheering up after the events of this week and to find out which of our do you want to describe them tom um using your time-honored phrase historical hunks and babes to find out which of the hunks and babes
问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和抢先体验现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
will be what will they be doing well so there will be four couples at the end of the show and they will be going up for public vote so you can decide who wins historical love island 2022 it couldn't be more exciting coming on monday do not miss it that dream couple of judas oscarit and virginia wolf emerge triumphant wait and see it couldn't be it couldn't be more exciting it's much more exciting than politics right goodbye everybody bye more exciting than politics right goodbye everybody bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our
他们会做什么呢？节目最后会有四对情侣，他们将接受公众投票，所以你可以决定谁能赢得2022年历史版恋爱岛的冠军。这太令人兴奋了，周一播出，千万不要错过。犹大、奥斯卡和弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫那对梦幻情侣会胜出吗？拭目以待吧，这太令人兴奋了，比政治有趣多了，对吧？再见大家，再见。感谢收听《历史的余韵》。想要收听奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。网址是restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余韵》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的
Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和抢先购买现场演出门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。